[Music]
this morning the Undisputed heavyweight
champion of national parks no other Park
comes close to how big Wrangle Saint
Elias is if you're unfamiliar with it
that's likely because it's not exactly
easy to reach sitting on the edge of
Alaska an eight-hour drive from
Anchorage
13.2 million pristine Acres with an
active volcano nine of the 16 highest
peaks in America and countless glaciers
Wrangle St Elias also contains the last
Community inside a national park about a
hundred full-time residents who were
convinced the best way to live
is far away from everyone else
[Music]
famous as other attractions but Wrangle
Saint Elias National Park is larger than
Yellowstone Yosemite and Switzerland
combined there's no other way to get an
idea for the scale the scope of this
place than being up here yeah this park
as massive as it is would be completely
underappreciated without Aviation Austin
Robel of wrangle Mountain Air gave us
the big picture from above
if you guys look in the ice sometimes
you can see layers
that function basically the same as tree
rings and you can count those like tree
rings and see how many years worth of
ice you're looking at
for millions of years Wrangle St Elias
has been shaped by the competing forces
of volcanism and glaciation
volcanic and glacial activity
Fire and Ice
a hundred years ago the section of the
park we flew over was mined heavily but
no more the Alaska lands conservation
Act of 1980 protected
157 million acres in our 49 States
including Wrangle Saint Elias
right in the middle of that a throwback
to the days of the Kennicott mining
operation is still thriving we're in the
Park yeah we're in the geographic center
of the park
I mean it's it's as Central as you can
be in the park McCarthy is a
one-of-a-kind private Town accessible
only by plane a privately owned Bridge
or a footpath this was once Sin City
yeah like the quintessential Sin City I
mean it was moonshining gambling
prostitution today it's a little
different
Neil darrish is the town's largest
landowner one of the business people
serving a small year-round population of
locals and a growing number of seasonal
tourists when people go out into the
Wilderness and then they come here and
they're able to relax or they're able to
have
a cold beer or whatever that's part of
the human condition today they want to
experience the unpredictable they want
to be surprised by an animal they don't
want to get eaten by a bear
so finding the way to help people
enjoy their Adventure that's really our
role in this area Adventure is not hard
to come by
it's wild walking through here it's it's
quite a spot isn't it yeah I mean
time forgotten Mike loso a geologist
with a National Park Service showed us
the restored buildings that once served
as the heart of mining town you know
what they ought to have here is a chase
scene not to mention the site of this
elaborate video from John Denver's 1978
film Alaska the American child
the John Denver fan not many people
admit I love John do you nice good makes
me like you I'm a John Denver fan too
huge John Denver fan Wrangle Saint Elias
is one of the only places in the world
you can with reasonable efforts actually
walk on a glacier we go out this Trail a
lot we're gonna see Bears maybe wouldn't
surprise me the five mile hike takes you
through some of the most Majestic Beauty
this land has to offer
along with interesting encounters on the
way
so there
staring at us
I mean he could come down and attack us
right now but I would say he's probably
not going to no he's running away yeah
that's what we like him to do
we like to look at him and then watch
him leave
well that's cool that's cool yeah really
a little black bear yeah
it's not little yeah no he wasn't little
it's good that you brought the bear
spray
right you didn't he didn't bring the
bear spray
FYI
the glacier we travel to Tells A
Familiar story when I first came to this
Valley for the very first time in 1990
coming down this Trail you'd you'd get
on the ice just below where we're
standing right here and as you can see
the ice Edge is quite a distance away
we're going to walk it here in a moment
and you'll feel how far it is but that's
a measure in you know part of a human
lifetime of how far this Glacier is
retreated the irregular shape of the
surface is a product of different areas
melting at different rates based on sun
exposure Rock debris covers some parts
more than others the basic idea and this
is a good place to point it out is
a very thin layer of dirt
absorbs more sunlight and melts faster
but a thick layer of dirt like this just
a couple centimeters thick
is enough to insulate the ice from the
Sun
and so it melts slower while cycles of
glaciers growing and receding over
hundreds of years are normal the rate of
melting over the last half century is
impossible to ignore how many feet down
it has it gone
at this particular location about 200
feet give or take and when you go down
to the the Terminus of the glacier just
a little ways Downstream of us there's a
huge Lake there now we call that a
pro-glacial lake and that Lake didn't
even exist when I first came here it
doesn't even have a name it's so new and
this summer my son and I are going to
build a sailboat
and start sailing on that Lake really
that's the future
making the best of a new reality while
studying ways to preserve what's left
as our time on the Kennecott Glacier
Drew to a close another group of
adventurers were heading toward the ice
drawn by The Bucket List chance to visit
this Undisputed heavyweight champion of
national parks you know part of it is
those statistics you were just citing
they even sort of hide the truth of it
because 13.2 million Acres well that's
the park boundary but that boundary in
most directions is arbitrary it's more
Mountains more Wilderness more glaciers
North America's Mountain Kingdom that's
the term I prefer so you're saying the
park is actually bigger than it is which
is already the biggest
the protected lands
in this area are much bigger than just
Wrangle St Elias National Park and
preserve it's the core of a much bigger
protected landscape
how awesome is that super awesome
you and you look out in the park
wherever you are just in awe and just
try to soak it in but it is so big and
it is so beautiful all the different
terrain that you were showing us and I'm
thinking is watching that most of us are
never going to go there thank you for
taking us there but how is it really
amazing how is it we don't know or never
heard of this place being the
heavyweight that it is well because it's
on the edge of Alaska and because it's
as we said it's not easy to get to at
all so you have to make that commitment
but more and more people are and I think
it's it's starting to get a little more
attention and especially walking on a
glacier yeah right I think you've like
sparked or ignited some more Insurance
some more interesting Elias